Speaker 1: All right, this year, I think you're
just going to absolutely love the absurdity of
this. After much waiting and excitement and
anticipation and waiting with bated breath.
He's finally done it. Donald Trump has announced
his new media group and a new free speech
platform called Truth Social. Finally, you
will be freed from the chains of Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and Tik Tok
and all these different places that suppress your
speech. You will have full free speech on truth
social, except not really. Let's go through this
piece by piece. First, the announcement TMT G
announcing this is yesterday. Late yesterday
announcing Trump media and technology group Trump
Media and Technology Group and Digital World
Acquisition Corp. have entered into a definitive
merger agreement, providing for a business
combination that will result in Trump media
and technology group becoming a publicly listed
company subject to regulatory and stockholder
approval. The transaction values Trump Media
and Technology Group at an initial enterprise
value of eight hundred and seventy five million
dollars. Wow. With a potential additional earn out
of $825 million in additional shares going on to
say Trump Media and Technology Group's mission is
to create a rival to the liberal media consortium
and fight back against the big tech companies of
Silicon Valley, which have used their unilateral
power to silence opposing voices in America. Just
wait until what I'm going to show you goes up on
the screen. Trump Media and Technology Group
will soon be launching a social network named
Truth Social Truth Social is now available
for preorder in the Apple App Store. Truth
Social plans to begin its beta launch for invited
guests in November of 21. A nationwide rollout is
expected in the first quarter of twenty two.
You can sign up a truth social dot com, Trump,
the chairman of the Trump Media and Technology
Group, stated. Imagine Trump as a tech CEO.
I created Truth Social and TMT to stand up to the
tyranny of Big Tech. We live in a world where the
Taliban has a huge presence on Twitter. Yet your
favorite American president has been silenced.
This is unacceptable, says Trump. I am excited
to send out my first truth. Untruth Social very
soon to MTG was founded with a mission to give
voice to all. Wow, that's great. I'm excited
to soon begin sharing my thoughts on truth, social
and fight back against Big Tech. Everyone asks me,
Sir, why doesn't someone stand up to Big Tech?
Well, we all we will be soon. Don Jr. already
appearing last night on Fox News to promote it,
and it's going to be an exercise in unfettered
free speech for all. Anything goes folks and
Speaker 2: free network for people to be able
to communicate to exercise your First Amendment
rights, right? And so tonight, my father signed
a definitive merger agreement to form what will
ultimately be the Trump media, and it's funny
Speaker 1: how Don calls it a definitive
merger agreement. Yet the announcement
said it's all subject to approval.
But OK, but that's not the focus
Speaker 2: group and Truth Social, a platform for
everyone to express their feelings, Big Tech and
all of those on the left. For so long, Sean has
been saying, Well, if you don't like the rules
that we really enforce, only one way on our
platforms, go create your own right. So we did
just that. So that's going to launch very soon.
We're going to be in beta testing in the next few
weeks to full launch first quarter of twenty two.
Yeah, it's going to be exciting and we're looking
to give a voice back to the American people. Wow.
Speaker 1: Well, that's all really, really
exciting. Express your feelings. No censorship,
all of this stuff. It's great. Except oh,
the terms of service of Trump's truth. Social
don't allow criticizing truth. Social Oh,
what's going on? The 23rd rule, which I'm
putting up on the screen for Trump's planned
social media site, is you can't make fun of or
criticize his social media site number 23. You
are not allowed to quote, disparage, tarnish or
otherwise harm. Wait a second. In our opinion,
us and or the site, folks, that's not very free
speech, isn't it? And it's important to mention
on Facebook you can criticize Facebook on YouTube,
you can criticize YouTube. We've done it when we
feel we've been treated unfairly by YouTube, we
publish it to YouTube, and it's fine. On Twitter,
you can criticize Twitter on Instagram, you can
criticize Instagram. They don't ban people for
criticizing them. And yet on the Trump social
site, which is all about freedom and free speech
and everybody there. You know, no censorship, you
are not allowed to criticize the site itself. Now
at the at the risk of getting a little bit into
the weeds, the other funny thing about this
is that the terms of service also include a
dispute resolution clause that Trump's lawyers
just got done arguing are unenforceable in
a different venue, according to Brad Heath,
who's the D.C. crime and justice reporter.
The rules for Trump's site have this
dispute resolution thing, which says any dispute,
controversy or claim you have arising related to
these Terms of Service, a breach thereof or your
use of the site shall be exclusively submitted and
decided by binding arbitration administered by the
American Arbitration Association. Any legal action
of whatever nature brought against us, brought
by us against you may be commenced or prosecuted
in the state and federal courts in Broward County,
and you consent to the same. So basically, they're
saying if you come after us, it's all going
to be handled by this arbitration association,
which is great for them. But if we bring a cause
against you, it's going to court. And this is
exactly this is exactly what Trump's lawyers just
got done. Arguing is actually not enforceable, so
they don't care about principles of free speech
or no censorship. They don't care about principles
when it comes to arbitration. They'll argue one
thing if it's good for them and they'll argue the
opposite if it's good for them. And we know this
because even now, they only care about censorship
and silencing in terms of service when they
perceive that a right wing voice is being limited,
which sometimes happens when they're inciting
violence or spreading horrible disinformation.
But now they don't care about those very same
principles as I've told you hundreds of times.
And here is more proof. It's just about what
benefits us, right? Right now, these people
are pathetic and maybe just as pathetic.
Trump's social media site was already hacked